More than 50,000 Americans are currently on
the waitlist for a new kidney.
And a new procedure means that they could
receive a kidney from any donor in the world.
Hello everyone!
Amy digging into some neat body stuff with
you on DNews today.
Specifically, kidneys.
Kidneys are great.
They clean our blood and make hormones that
keep our bones strong and our blood healthy.
But they can fail.
While we can live with one kidney, we can't
live with none, so in cases of double kidney
failure a transplant is really the best option.
A kidney transplant, like any organ transplant,
works best if there’s a match between the
donor and the recipient.
That's because our bodies are pretty good
at rejecting foreign objects.
The cells that make up any organ have antigens,
and if the organ’s antigens are different
from the host’s body, it triggers an immune
response and the body will attack the new
organ.
So transplants demand that doctors “type”
both the donor and recipient to establish
whether the pair are a match.
A perfect match means both people have the
same blood type and compatibility between
six Human Leukocyte Antigens.
No two people are exactly the same, but the
more similar two people’s antigens are the
more likely the transplant will be a success,
although finding a good match can be incredibly
difficult.
So doctors will use drugs to suppress the
recipient’s immune system to lower the chances
of the body attacking the transplanted kidney.
But a new process called desensitization detailed
in The New England Journal of Medicine offers
a new solution: altering a recipient’s immune
system without drugs to allow him or her to
accept a kidney from an incompatible donor.
The process involves filtering the antibodies
out of a recipient's blood and replacing them
with antibodies that match the donor, making
the two people more compatible.
Now, this won’t change the recipient’s
blood forever; eventually their immune system
will replenish itself with its own antibodies.
But here's the super cool but super weird
bit: experts don't totally know why, but those
regenerated antibodies are less likely to
attack the newly transplanted organ!
The promising results come from a 22-center
study looking at 1,025 kidney transplant recipients.
Those who went through the desensitization
process had a significantly higher survival
rate: 76.5 percent of them were still alive
eight years after the transplant.
Compare that to recipients who stayed on the
waitlist to eventually get a compatible kidney.
This group had a survival rate of 62.9 percent.
So it’s a relatively small sample size,
but it's promising.
And it could change so many lives.
Currently, patients unable to find compatible
donors have no other option but dialysis,
a regular procedure that filters your blood
to get rid of waste, extra salt, and water.
It's doing a kidney’s job without having
a working kidney but it’s far from ideal
and can be detrimental to a patient's health,
long-term.
Desensitization could mean thousands of people
would be spared a life of these constant treatments.
The human body is fascinating, and sometimes,
we don’t have enough time to talk about
it on DNews!
Luckily, Trace takes on these kinds of topics
on Test Tube Plus.
So click here now to Subscribe to that channel
to watch it first.